[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen meine sehr verehrten Damen und
Herren wenn man auf das Jahr
2022 zurückblickt muss man glaube ich
sagen es war und ist ein Jahr wie kaum
ein anderes
es ist ein Jahr das durch Putins
aggressiven Angriffskrieg wieder auf
diesen Kontinent gebracht hat es ist ein
Jahr das vermeintliche Gewissheiten
beschädigt oder sogar zerstört hat aber
es ist auch ein Jahr das
und in Deutschland und Europa angespornt
hat
entschlossener und geschlossener zu
handeln und es ist ein Jahr
das nachdrücklich und eindrücklich zeigt
eine
souveräne
soziale starke Europäische Union ist
unverzichtbar liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
und
wenn ich zur Regierungsbank gucke und
zum Bundeskanzler kann ich für meine
Fraktion für die SPD-Bundestagsfraktion
gerade nach diesem Jahr und in diesem
Jahr erklären wir bedanken uns für die
Entschlossenheit und Besonnenheit der
gesamten Bundesregierung des
Bundeskanzlers Olaf Scholz
und diese Bundesregierung handelt in
Deutschland mit dem Sondervermögen
Bundeswehr mit drei entlastungspaketen
mit dem 200 Milliarden Paket das wir in
dieser Woche beschließen werden zur
Deckelung von Energiepreisen zur Deckung
von explodierenden Energiepreisen und
diese Bundesregierung handelt in Europa
außenpolitisch gegenüber Russland
mittlerweile mit neuen sanktionspaketen
sanktionspakete die ist so noch nie
gegeben hat in der Geschichte der
Europäischen Union sie handelt gegenüber
dem Iran mit einer Klarheit und
Entschlossenheit die sie von anderen
Lena Werbung vorgetragen wird und auch
vom Bundeskanzler wie ich sie noch nie
erlebt habe in der letzten 20 oder 30
Jahren und das mal ganz klar zu sagen
und sie handelt
im Blick auf die nächsten notwendigen
erweiterungsschritte fast 20 Jahre nach
dem Gipfel den Kopenhagen wo die bislang
größte Erweiterung beschlossen wurde mit
klaren Kriterien wann man beitreten darf
und wann nicht haben wir uns jetzt auf
den Weg gemacht nachdem jahrelang nichts
passiert ist unter der Führung dieses
Bundeskanzlers die nächsten Schritte zur
Erweiterung der Europäischen Union um
den westlichen Balkan zu machen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und diese Bundesregierung handelt auch
sicherheitspolitisch und
verteidigungspolitisch in einer Art und
Weise wie wir uns das wahrscheinlich
alle vor zehn Monaten noch nicht
vorstellen konnten mit dem
Sondervermögen Bundeswehr und auch mit
deutsch-französischen Projekten die
jahrelang in der großen Koalition
verhakt waren und wurden nichts
weiterging als sie die
Verteidigungsminister gestellt haben
nämlich mit dem Waffensystem dem neuen
Bomber FKS ein deutsch-französisches
Großprojekt für die nächsten Jahre und
Jahrzehnte liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
und wir handeln das gehört nämlich auch
dazu auch
entwicklungspolitisch auch wenn man auf
humanitäre Hilfe guckt das was
Deutschland in den letzten zehn Monaten
für die Ukraine geleistet hat ist
wirklich vorbildlich und es ist ganz
billig das eine oder andere rauszusuchen
was einem gerade nicht passt lieber
Kollege Merz und wenn ich schon mal bei
ihnen bin
das einzige was mich irritiert bei ihren
Reden ist immer der Anfangsteil der
Anfangsteil ist immer staatsmännisch
kooperativ es stellt sich am Fluss ihrer
Rede immer raus das ist nur gespielt es
reicht nur zum reklam-staatsmann Herr
Merz
und das was Sie angesprochen haben Herr
bartscht natürlich natürlich muss man
natürlich muss man auch bei einer
solchen Regierungserklärung an einem
solchen Tag vor zwei wichtigen Gipfeln
darüber reden was nicht klappt in der
Europäischen Union oder wo es Missstände
gibt und ich fange mal an ja es gibt
keinen Skandal der Sozialdemokraten in
der im Europäischen Parlament es gibt
einen Skandal von einzelnen
Sozialdemokraten im Europäischen
Parlament das ist was das ist richtig
und das sprechen wir ganz das sprechen
wir ganz offen an ich hätte mich gefreut
wenn Sie das bei den meisten Skandalen
und andere Sachen genauso gemacht hätten
das was ich da was ich da zeigt ist
zweier allein was sich da zeigt das
zweierlei ein ab ein Abgrund an habt ihr
und ein Abgrund an Korruption aber es
zeigt sich auch innerhalb von fünf Tagen
innerhalb von fünf Tagen Ausschluss aus
der Partei aus der Fraktion und ein
Beschluss des Europäischen Parlamentes
Absetzung als Vizepräsidentin das ist
schnelles Handeln in fünf Tagen ist sie
aber uns mehr passiert als bei anderen
in fünf Jahren und es gibt noch was
worüber man reden muss
der Kollege dürr hat das zurecht
angesprochen natürlich ist die
Europäische Union mit 27 Staaten nicht
so dass alle so sind wie wir oder alle
so sind wie Frankreich oder alle so sind
wieder Niederlande nein das liegt in der
Natur der Sache wenn ich nach und nach
versuche die Europäische Union zu
erweitern es liegt nicht in der Natur
der Sache das ein
ige meinen sie müssen sich nicht an
Rechtsstaatlichkeit Demokratie
Pressefreiheit halten wie zum Beispiel
Ungarn und deshalb liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen ist es richtig dass ein
Meilenstein gesetzt wurde mit dem
Vorgehen der Europäischen Union
gegenüber Ungarn Geld scheint doch
wichtige Waffe zu sein um solche Leuten
als jeder zu kommen und er ist ebenfalls
kein Gewinner der letzten Woche er ist
der große Verlierer in Europa der große
Verlierer in Europa heißt Viktor Orban
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und zusammengefasst wir haben für 2023
den von dem morgigen Gipfel viel vor in
Europa wir werden in der Wirtschafts-
und Industriepolitik mit diesem
Wirtschaftsminister die
industriepolitische Agenda in Europa neu
schreiben wir werden bei den Beihilfen
deutlich mehr machen als bisher und wir
werden auf der Höhe der Zeit sein wenn
es darum geht uns neu aufzustellen was
die Wirtschaft und Industriepolitik in
Europa angeht liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen und der letzte Punkt und der
letzte Punkt ich bin sicher
dass das was der Bundeskanzler in Prag
erklärt hat dass der Fahrplan für
realistischen Fortschritt in der
Europäischen Union Schritt für Schritt
umgesetzt wird der erste Schritt dafür
wird auf diesem Gipfel passieren die
nächsten werden folgenden schönen Dank
nächster Redner für die cdu/csu-fraktion
Alexander Dobrindt
sehr geehrte Präsidentin werte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen der
Bundeskanzler sie haben den
Vernichtungskrieg Putins gegen die
Zivilbevölkerung in der Ukraine
angesprochen sie haben noch mal deutlich
bekräftigt dass sie an der Seite der
Ukraine stehen wir unterstützen Sie bei
diesem Anliegen ausdrücklich immer und
immer wieder aber was sie heute erneut
nicht gesagt haben und das muss das
Leitmotiv all unsere Handlungen sein die
Ukraine muss diesen Krieg gewinnen was
ist so schwer daran
sie haben darüber gesprochen dass sie
Europa zusammenhalten wollen in ihrer
ersten Regierungserklärung der
Bundeskanzler haben sie gesagt dass sie
in Europa Brücken bauen wollen die
Bilanz allerdings in ihrem ersten Jahr
ihre Regierung ist doch eher dass sie
Deutschland in Europa zunehmend isoliert
haben es ist ihre
Verteidigungsministerin die Polen vor
den Kopf gestoßen hat weil sie
petritvereinbarungen nicht geheim halten
konnte es ist ihr Wirtschaftsminister
der Schweden vor den Kopf gestoßen hat
weil er aus ideologischen Gründen die
kernenergieversorgung Schwedens
gefährdet sie selber liegen mit dem
französischen Präsidenten im Streit Herr
Bundeskanzler der deutsch-französische
Motor in Europa er stottert sie bauen
keine Brücken sie reisen Sie ein das ist
die Wahrheit in Europa
sie haben hier intensiv heute über ihre
Neuausrichtung der Verteidigungspolitik
gesprochen sie haben in ihrer
Zeitenwende rede ja auch von einer
aufrüstungsoffensive gesprochen und
diese versprochen aber wie schaut denn
die Bilanz am Ende dieses Jahres aus
zwei Prozent für die Verteidigung sie
halten sie nicht ein zehn Milliarden für
die munitionsbeschaffung sie halten sie
nicht ein 100 Milliarden Sondervermögen
ausgeben für Beschaffung sie halten es
nicht ein ihre
Verteidigungsministerin organisiert
anstatt der Zeitenwende die Zeiten
Verschwendung das hat mit Fortschritt
nichts zu tun
und Sie haben ja auch von der
Energiesicherheit gesprochen in ihrer
Rede hier im Deutschen Bundestag am 1
Juni haben sie gesagt Energie muss immer
verfügbar sein 24 Stunden am Tag 365
Tage im Jahr die Realität heute ist eine
andere erst hat die Wirtschaftsminister
das Stromproblem grundsätzlich geleugnet
dann haben die Grünen ein Strom
sonderproblem für Bayern erfunden jetzt
erklärt dass grüne
ministerpräsidentenland
Baden-Württemberg hören Sie einfach zu
das grüne
ministerpräsidentenland
Baden-Württemberg erklärt dass
Abschaltung der Stromversorgung nicht
mehr auszuschließen sind ja Herr Habig
sie schalten die Kernkraftwerke ab
anstatt den Verstand ein ich würde Ihnen
sagen das hat mit Blackout nichts zu tun
das ist ein green out den wir hier
erwarten können
und weil wir ja über ihre Bilanz hier
auch reden der Bundesfinanzminister der
hat in dem letzten Monat noch gesagt
dass sie als Koalition nicht
beabsichtigten Steuern zu erhöhen letzte
Woche haben sie hier im Deutschen
Bundestag eine massive Erhöhung der
Erbschaftssteuer beschlossen vielleicht
vielleicht haben vielleicht haben sie
das etwas spät bemerkt und weil sie Herr
dürften der FDP hier wieder den Namen
Horst Seehofer Zwischenrufen will ich
Ihnen schon mal sagen wir haben uns ja
daran gewöhnt dass sie von ihrer
Mitverantwortung in den letzten 20
Jahren in der deutschen Politik nichts
mehr hören wollen aber dass sie jetzt
schon ihre Mitverantwortung bei den
Entscheidungen von letzter Woche nichts
mehr wissen wollen das ist in der Tat
eine ganz neue Version
auch wenn Ihnen das möglicherweise hier
spät aufgefallen ist sie haben in der
letzten Woche die Freibeträge nicht
erhöht jetzt kommen sie drauf gestern
ganz offensichtlich dass man Freibeträge
erhöhen muss und schieben die
Verantwortung den Ländern zu ich sage
Ihnen wenn Sie bereit sind die
Freibeträge zu erhöhen dann liegt der
Ball immer noch im Finanzministerium
dann machen Sie doch einen Gesetzentwurf
dass die Freibeträge erhöht werden und
die Erbschaftssteuer die steigt wir sind
sofort dabei dies mitzumachen
und jetzt zum Schluss nur den Hinweis
der Bundeskanzler sie haben den Menschen
Respekt versprochen in ihrer ersten Rede
als Bundeskanzler kommt dieses Wort 30
Mal vor in ihrer letzten Rede und auch
heute Herr Bundeskanzler ist davon keine
Rede mehr ich wünsche mir für ihre
zweites Jahr in ihrer Amtszeit dass sie
wieder mehr über Respekt reden und
übrigens auch danach handeln Respekt
gegenüber unseren europäischen Partnern
Respekt gegenüber der nächsten
Generation Respekt gegenüber der
Leistung der Menschen in unserem Land
und übrigens auch als Weihnachtsgruß
Herr Dürre Respekt auch gegenüber der
Opposition ich kann mal sagen ich habe
selten eine so destruktive rede hier im
Deutschen Bundestag von einer
regierungs-koalition gehört die von
Ihnen erwartet danke schön
nächster Redner für die Fraktion Bündnis
90 die Grünen Jürgen Trittin
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
lieber Herr dobre und ich glaube Sie
haben ja gleich mehrere Chancen verpasst
die erste Chance wäre gewesen
dass Sie sich hier für das unselige
sharepic entschuldigen was ukrainische
Flüchtlinge im ankunftszentrum in Tegel
zeigt Solidarität mit der Ukraine heißt
Solidarität mit dem Menschen und heißt
nicht Politik Zulassen von geflüchteten
aus der Ukraine zu machen
die zweite Gelegenheit die sie verpasst
haben
sie hätten sich hier endlich mal für den
Begriff der klima-raf entschuldigen
können und wissen Sie warum ich das an
dieser Woche sage
weil wir gerade damit konfrontiert
worden sind was die wahre terroristische
Herausforderung in diesem Lande ist
nämlich der bewaffnete Arm der
Reichsbürger mit den Beziehungen der AFD
hin kein Wort von ihnen kein scherpick
gar nichts das ist ein Massen mit
doppelter Moral
und vielleicht vielleicht sollten Sie
wenn wir über Europa sprechen
sich der Ernsthaftigkeit einig der
delegitimation dieses jüngsten
korruptionskandals
an der Stelle hätte ich mir eigentlich
gewünscht dass die CSU sagt ja
wir überdenken unsere Position noch mal
denn angesichts der bargeldhaufen die da
gefunden worden sind weiterhin dagegen
zu sein dass es eine Obergrenze für
Bargeldzahlungen gibt das ist meines
Erachtens genau die falsche Konsequenz
aus diesem Skandal
und letzte Bemerkung
wenn sie mir schon den Gefallen tun
CSU-Mitglied als CSU-Mitglied über
Energiepolitik zu sprechen
dann erlaube ich mir die freundliche
Frage
wer hat dann die Situation herbeigeführt
dass die deutschen Netzbetreiber
festgestellt haben dass wir zwei
Norddeutschland eine Überkapazität von
Strom haben wir nicht wissen wohin damit
wir zum Teil Windparks abschalten müssen
aber in Bayern eine mangelage droht ich
kann Ihnen das Beantworten wer dafür
verantwortlich ist das ist der
esoterische einzelgang der CSU gewesen
die gewollt hat dass Gott keine
windelergie produziert hat und die jede
Stromleitung aus dem Norden in den Süden
blockiert hat wenn jemand ein
energiepolitischer Geisterfahrer ist
dann ist es die zählt so in Deutschland
letzte Bemerkung meine Damen und Herren
das ist ja gelegentlich die traurige
Wirklichkeit die wir vorgefunden haben
als die Regierung übernommen haben
und die Frage wie wir in Europa
die wir in Europa mit dieser Situation
umgehen darauf hat diese Bundesregierung
eine Antwort gefunden
wir sind diejenigen die zum Beispiel in
global Gateway es vorantreiben in
Namibia in Chile mit dem Ausbau im
großen Stil erneuerbare Energien
Wasserstoff zu erzeugen aber
wir gehen auch nicht nur hin und sagen
wir machen dieses neue wir sichern die
Energieversorgung für morgen das ist
übrigens wenn ich das sagen darf nicht
nur eine gute Nachricht für die
Energieunabhängigkeit Deutschlands das
ist auch und gerade ein
partnerschaftliches Verständnis im
Umgang mit Ländern wie Namibia an dieser
Stelle das ist ein riesige
Entwicklungschance für diese Länder
aber
wir nehmen als G7 Länder auf viel Geld
in die Hand um beispielsweise gemeinsam
mit Südafrika deren Abhängigkeit von
Kohle zu überwinden das ist unsere
Antwort auf die Herausforderung vor der
dieses gemeinsame Europa steht
angesichts einer drohenden Bipolarität
zwischen den USA und China und diese
Antwort die gibt diese Bundesregierung
dafür Danke
nächster Redner für die FDP-Fraktion
Alexander
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
was für ein Jahr neigt sich diesem Ende
zu ein Jahr wirklich großer dramatischer
Zäsuren der größte Landkrieg in Europa
seit dem Zweiten Weltkrieg ist
ausgebrochen
gleichzeitig ist es auch eine Zäsur wie
fest der Westen zusammensteht wer hätte
es zu Beginn dieses Jahres zu Beginn der
Invasion gedacht dass die schrecklichen
Entwicklungen der Versuch von Russlands
total Eroberung der Ukraine so umfassend
scheitern würde wie wir das jetzt
beobachten Putins außenpolitischer
Handlungsspielraum ist deutlich
geschrumpft aber auch im Inneren auch im
Inneren scheint die russische Regierung
ihre eigene Legitimität in Frage
gestellt zu sehen zum ersten Mal seit
zehn Jahren
fällt die Jahrespressekonferenz des
russischen Präsidenten aus meine Damen
und Herren das ist eine bemerkenswerte
Entwicklung ganz offensichtlich sieht
sich Präsident Putin auch im Inland
inzwischen dem Druck ausgesetzt seine
Bevölkerung nach der Mobilisierung diese
schrecklichen Krieg zu beenden wir
können nur hoffen dass dieser Druck sich
auch dahingehend dass der Krieg eines
Tages ändert
zurzeit
das muss man auch so deutlich sagen gibt
es keinen Anlass zu Entspannung in der
Ukraine verfolgt Russland zurzeit eine
Politik der verbrannten Erde und diese
Art der Kriegsführung wirkt auch für uns
in Zukunft Risiken und Gefahren für die
wir in Deutschland und Europa gewappnet
sein müssen was bedeutet das gewappnet
sein es bedeutet das was wir im
Koalitionsvertrag festgehalten haben
erstens das transatlantische Bündnis des
zentraler Pfeiler und zweitens die NATO
bleibt unverzichtbare Grundlage unserer
Sicherheit und drittens so haben wir es
im Koalitionsvertrag festgehalten unsere
Soldaten und Soldaten leisten einen
unentbehrlichen Beitrag zum Schutz
unseres Landes für Frieden und
internationale Sicherheit sie stehen
immerhin mit der Luftwaffe in Russland
mit dem her die NATO Luftabwehr in der
Slowakei wird gestärkt und in dieser
Woche wird auch in Polen die Luft Abwehr
verstärkt meine Damen und Herren wir
hier genau wie unsere Wählerinnen und
Wähler können Advent und Weihnachten
voraussichtlich zu Hause
in der Heimat bei unseren Lieben feiern
für viele Soldatinnen und Soldaten gilt
das nicht die leisten ihren Dienstplan
der Heimat auf in Mali oder Estland
Litauen oder dem Libanon Südsudan oder
der Slowakei wir denken an Sie und wir
danken ihnen für ihren Einsatz und
wünschen ihnen friedliche und fröhliche
Weihnachten fern der Heimat herzlichen
Dank
nächster Redner der fraktionslose
Abgeordnete Robert fahle
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrter Herr Bundeskanzler sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren die Bundesregierung
tritt jetzt mit der zugesagten
Ausbildung von 5000 Mann ukrainischen
Kampftruppen auf deutschem Territorium
ganz bewusst in den ukrainischen Krieg
gegen Russland ein mit dem Ziel eine
militärische Niederlage Russlands zu
ermöglichen was offensichtlich durch die
immer schärfere Sanktionspolitik der EU
im Wirtschaftskrieg gegen Russland nicht
erreicht werden kann für diese ständig
weitergehen der Eskalation der
Beteiligung Deutschlands an dem Krieg
gegen Russland gibt es keine
völkerrechtliche Grundlage und sie
verstößt eindeutig gegen das
aggressionsverbot unseres Grundgesetzes
nach Artikel 26 Absatz 1
spätestens seit zielenskiste Krebs
Nummer 117 vom März 2021 zu Eroberung
der Grimm steht zweifelsfrei fest dass
die Ukraine gestützt auf die USA und
Teile der EU ein Angriffskrieg gegen
Russland vorbereitet hat
Salewski verteidigt keine westlichen
Werte er ist korrupt er hat die
Opposition in seinem Land verboten die
Medien gleichgeschaltet
Kriegsverbrechen zu verantworten
Friedensverhandlungen mit Russland per
Dekret verboten lässt Kollaborateure
foltern und ermortern für Terroraktionen
durch und versucht durch gezielte
Provokationen immer mehr westliche
Länder in seinen Krieg hineinzuziehen
das ist alles belegt durch
Zeitungsmeldungen im Fokus und der Welt
sehr geehrter Herr Bundeskanzler ich
appelliere an Sie reichen sie dem
französischen Präsidenten macron die
Hand und unterstützen sie seinen
Vorschlag für sofortige
Waffenstillstandsverhandlungen und die
Schaffung einer europäischen
Sicherheitsarchitektur unter Wahrung der
Sicherheitsinteressen aller Beteiligten
unter Einschluss der Russischen
Föderation nach Kräften voranzutreiben
und nein Herr Dobrindt die Ukraine muss
nicht gewinnen der Frieden muss gewinnen
wir brauchen keinen nuklearen Winter
jemals in Europa und Karin Deutschland
und nicht in der ganzen Welt machen sie
endlich eine friedensoffensive das ist
die Aufgabe diese Regierung auch wenn
sie nicht ihren Amtszeit brechen wollen
und wenn sie den brechen wollen werden
sie ihre Quittung bei der nächsten
Wahlen bekommen Vielen Dank
selbst für die AFD zurecht ich sag mal
was heißen
übrigens der Kanzler der Kanzler hat mir
gerade mitgeteilt dass er los muss zum
Europäischen Rat und bitte deshalb und
Entschuldigung dass er die letzten
Rednerinnen und Redner
nur nur virtuell verfolgen kann
wir machen aber jetzt weiter nächster
Redner für die SPD-Fraktion Axel Schäfer
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen
Kollegen nach der letzten Rede muss man
feststellen als kann sein wenn man
lebenslang Stalinist ist und im Alter
dann rechtsextrem wird dass das beides
sehr sehr nah beieinander legt und
trotzdem ist das tragisch und dramatisch
und wir müssen das gemeinsam aufs
schärfste zurückweisen was erfahrene
gerade gesagt hat
deshalb reden wir über Europa und reden
wir und reden wir darüber dass es
gelingt Olaf Scholz hat zurecht gesagt
in seiner Prager Rede das Europa gelingt
brauchen wir Mehrheitsentscheidungen und
was das in der Praxis bedeutet haben wir
ja gesehen bei Einstimmigkeit war Orban
in der Lage
die Ukraine quasi in Geiselhaft zu
nehmen für Hilfen und es war gut dass
wir es geschafft haben jetzt zu einer
gemeinsamen Lösung zu kommen und es war
übrigens auch gut dass in diesem Hause
hier ganz viele zehn Jahre lang auf die
Union eingeredet haben kein Orban aus
der christdemokratischen Familie
auszuschließen irgendwann ist er dann
freiwillig gegangen und ich erinnere
mich sehr gut daran wie viel pilgerzüge
nach Budapest gegangen sind von München
aus um Orban zu unterstützen ich hoffe
das ist ein für alle Mal bei der Union
vorbei
und reden wir und reden wir dabei auch
reden wir dabei über die Praxis des
Bundeskanzlers er hat schon als
Finanzminister für globale Mindeststeuer
bei Unternehmen gekämpft zusammen mit
dem französischen Finanzminister Bruno
mehr das ist irgendwann mal Mehrheit
geworden und jetzt haben wir auch wieder
gegen die Blockade Ungarns das innerhalb
der Europäischen Union erreicht und das
ist ein großer Erfolg für Europa Politik
für diese Bundesregierung und für diesen
Bundeskanzler
und Kollege Merz das ist ja ganz leicht
zu behaupten wir wissen ja wie in
anderen Ländern zur Zeit über die
Bundesregierung oder über bestimmte
Unzuverlässigkeiten angeblicher Art
geredet wird ich habe in diesem Haus das
Privileg als einziger sowohl in der
Zukunftskonferenz Europas mit
Parlamentariern parlamentarien der EU
als auch in der Parlamentarischen
Versammlung des Europarates das sind
dann 46 Staaten zu wirken ich weiß sehr
wohl wie Parlamentarier und
Parlamentarier in den Mitgliedsländern
über uns denken was die von Deutschland
halten und erwarten das was Sie gesagt
haben ist pauschal und oberflächlich und
in der Konsequenz auch falsch
und und
lebe lieber Gunther Christbaum ich bin
in der Parlamentarischen Versammlung des
Europarates also mein Blick ist da schon
ein bisschen weiter als nur die
Zukunftskonferenz aber bleiben wir genau
bleiben wir bleiben wir bleiben wir
genau bleiben wir genau bei diesem Punkt
wir haben wir haben in der
Zukunftskonferenz gesagt wir müssen
stärker Bürgerinnen und Bürger
beteiligen
und wir haben als zentralen Punkt die
Demokratie zu entwickeln das Wahlalter
das heißt die Einbeziehung jüngerer
Menschen und in Deutschland ist das
gelungen von 25 über 21 auf 18 Jahre das
Wahlalter zum Bundestag zu senken die
CDU CSU
verweigert sich dem das heißt die gibt
vielen Millionen jüngeren Menschen nicht
die Chance der politischen Partizipation
und wir haben jetzt in Europa die
Forderung dass das insgesamt auch
realisiert wird und wir haben hier im
Bundestag deshalb dafür gestimmt dass
die nächste Direktwahl des Europäischen
Parlaments 2024 auch 16-Jährige
teilnehmen dürfen und das haben wir
gemeinsam in der Zukunftskonferenz so
gefordert und hier im Bundestag
beschlossen und die Union hat
geschlossen gegen diese Forderung
gestellt hier kann man ganz genau sehen
wie weit Europa gemeinsam von Ihnen
getragen und vorangetragen wird und
deshalb liebe Kolle und Kollegen wird es
wird es wichtig sein an dieser Stelle
deutlich zu machen wir haben in diesem
Jahr der größten Herausforderung Europas
seit 1945 bewiesen dass wir
handlungsfähig sind wir haben bewiesen
dass wir dieses Europa zusammenhalten
und deshalb war es in diesem Jahr zur
entscheidend eine Koalition aus Freien
Demokraten grüne und Sozialdemokratien
und Sozialdemokrat zu haben und so soll
es auch bleiben
[Applaus]
so
Kollege Schäfer sie haben den
Abgeordneten Falle
zur Person gerade angegriffen ich will
das zumindest sagen noch mal weil wir
uns hier vereinbart haben uns nicht
gegenseitig mit Ausdrücken zu
beschimpfen deswegen ist das zumindest
unparlamentarisch ich schaue mir aber
die genaue Formulierung im Nachgang mit
Protokoll noch mal an
nächste Rednerin für die
cdu/csu-fraktion Patricia lips
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin Kolleginnen und
Kollegen die Welt sortiert sich neu wir
haben es heute mehrfach gehört aber
nicht dass seit heute nur mit einer
sichtbaren Dynamik die Entwicklung liegt
schonungslos offen wir sind das größte
Land in der Europäischen Union auch
deshalb viele Augen richten sich nach
Deutschland in Zeiten wie diesen umso
mehr Europa braucht ein starkes
Deutschland aber um das zu sein brauchen
wir ein starkes funktionierendes Europa
und deshalb bleibt die Frage doch
wichtig wie wird unser Land aktuell
innerhalb der europäischen Familie
wahrgenommen sind wir als starker
verlässlicher berechenbarer Partner in
der manche wir haben also unsere Zweifel
und was noch wichtiger ist was ist
eigentlich die Vorstellung auch der
Bundesregierung von Europa was ist der
Kompass über den Tag hinaus der sie
leitet manches wurde bereits genannt am
heutigen Tag aber wenn wir es mit der
Zeitenwende ernst meinen dann müssen
weitere Tag folgen Europa steht mehr
denn je an einem Scheideweg lass diesen
Sie es uns deshalb auch mit einem
belastungsmoratorium ernst meinen ein
Begriff der heute noch gar nicht
gefallen ist wenigstens ein
regulierungs- oder Bürokratie Stopp wenn
schon der Abbau nicht hinreichend
gelingt das gilt für Maßnahmen im
eigenen Land aber aktuell umso mehr für
Maßnahmen auf europäische Ebene wir tun
an dieser Stelle oft so als seien diesen
Jahr gar nichts geschehen setzen Sie
sich dafür ein erfüllen sie ihren
eigenen Anspruch an die zeitenwände auch
an dieser Stelle Kolleginnen und
Kollegen nicht nur in Deutschland auch
Europa lebt vor allem durch die
Akzeptanz und dem Vertrauen der
Bürgerinnen und Bürger der
Planungssicherheit für unsere
lieber die unser Ziel muss zwingend
bleiben die Wettbewerbsfähigkeit Europas
zu stärken das allein sichert unseren
Wohlstand die Zeit allein wohlfeiler
Worte jedenfalls ist vorbei vielen Dank
nächster Redner für die SPD-Fraktion
Timon gremmels
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren ja vielen
Dank Herr Merz für ihre Ausbau Spartipps
die sie hier am Anfang gegeben haben
aber meine sehr verehrten Damen und in
diesem Jahr auf den Häuslebauer
Friedrich Merz gehört hätten dann hätten
wir es vielleicht ein schönes Haus aber
ein kaltes Haus weil die Hälfte der
Häuser gebaut hätte hätte keine
funktionierende Gasversorgung weil es
war doch sein Vorschlag im März dass wir
Nord Stream 1 vom Netz nehmen unsere
gastspeicher wären heute leer unsere
Häuser werden heute kalt so viel zur
energiepolitischen Kompetenz von
Friedrich Merz meine sehr verehrten
Damen und Herren diese Häuser kann er
selber bauen meine sehr verehrten Damen
und Herren ja wir werden auch in den
nächsten Tagen uns über den europäischen
gaspreisdeckel unterhalten und ich bin
sehr zuversichtlich dass auf den
Konferenzen aller spätestens am Montag
bei der
[Musik]
eu-ministerkonferenz in der
Energieminister wie der einen guten
europäischen Kompromiss hinbekommen
wichtig ist doch ober unser Ziel dass
wir in Europa genügend Brennstoff
bekommen genügend Gas bekommen und wir
müssen natürlich darauf aufpassen dass
ein zu hoher preisdeckel die Gefahr
birgt dass Gas in Europa knapp wird dass
die internationalen tankerflotte an
Europa vorbeifährt insofern haben wir da
eine Gesamtverantwortung wir brauchen
aber noch in diesem Jahr eine Lösung
weil alle weiteren Diskussionen die wir
führen wie zum Beispiel dem vom Kanzler
angesprochenen gemeinsamer Gaseinkauf
oder auch die genehmigungsbeschleunigung
die wir in Europa voranbringen derzeit
noch blockiert werden und deswegen ist
es sinnvoll und wichtig diese Fragen und
diesen Knoten zu durchschlagen und ich
bin sehr zuversichtlich dass sowohl der
Kanzler als auch Robert habe als unsere
Energie und Wirtschaftsminister diesen
Knoten in den nächsten Tagen
durchschlagen dafür sehr viel Erfolg
meine sehr verehrten Damen und
sie hatten ja gerade angesprochen der
deutsch-französische Motor würde stocken
ehrlich gesagt ich sehe das nicht so wir
haben an dieser Stelle doch wirklich
auch geholfen wir haben den Franzosen in
diesem Sommer geholfen weil es zur
Wahrheit gehört auch ein Teil des
steigenden Strompreises ein Teil unserer
gasknappheit hat doch damit etwas zu tun
dass wir im Sommer den Franzosen
ausgehalten haben bis heute ausgeholfen
haben weil 30 der 53 Atomkraftwerke in
Frankreich gar nicht am Netz waren wir
haben europäische Solidarität geleistet
und Energie nach Frankreich geliefert
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
und auch das muss an dieser Stelle
angesprochen werden und das ist auch ein
Beleg dafür dass Atomkraft keine Lösung
sein kann sondern nur ein Übergang sein
kann meine sehr verehrten Damen und
Herren insofern gehört auch zu weit dass
die Franzosen auch helfen indem sie Gas
liefern so funktioniert Europa und der
deutsch-französische Motor läuft meine
sehr verehrten Damen und Herren ja
und wir haben als Ampelkoalition in
diesem Jahr vieles vorangebracht wir
haben auch unidologisch Gehandelt ich
hätte mir im Januar diesen Jahres nicht
vorstellen können dass ich mal dafür
sein werde ng Terminals
flüssiggasthemals zu bauen es ist
richtig es ist notwendig dass als
Übergangstechnologie auch in Deutschland
zu installieren und ehrlich gesagt diese
neue Deutschland Geschwindigkeit die wir
da an den Tag gelegt haben erste
Überlegungen im Februar und jetzt die
erste Lieferung im Dezember ich würde
mir wünschen dass wir diese neue
Deutschland Geschwindigkeit auch für den
Ausbau der Erneuerbaren Energienutzen
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
das muss der Maßstab sein
das ist unser Thema ja und der Kanzler
hat auch deutlich gemacht dass die
Energiewende nicht nur ein Thema des
Klimaschutzes ist sondern auch ein Thema
der Energieunabhängigkeit lassen Sie
mich einen dritten Punkt anführen er ist
auch die Energiewende ist auch
industriepolitisch sinnvoll wir wollen
doch in Zukunft als Industrienation das
die Wärmepumpen dass die Wechselrichter
dass die Solarmodule dass die
Windturbinen dass die elektrolyseure
dass die Halbleiter hier in Deutschland
in Europa gebaut werden das sind die
Arbeitsplätze der Zukunft und wir als
Industrie Nationen wollen daran
partizipieren meine sehr verehrten Damen
und deswegen ist es so wichtig für uns
als Partei der Arbeit die ihre
Sozialdemokraten uns benennen dass wir
hier gemeinsam mit unseren europäischen
Freunden eine Antwort auf den Inflation
redakt der USA gemeinsam voranbringen
und wir sind da auf dem guten Weg meine
sehr geehrten Damen und Herren
und ich möchte an dieser Stelle auch
noch mal im Namen meiner Fraktion aber
sicherlich auch für die Koalition im
Kanzler danken dass die Idee des
klimaklubs die er auf dem Weg gebracht
hat von der Idee zur Umsetzung gekommen
ist dass er die g7-präsidentschaft dafür
benutzt hat eine solchen klimaklub
voranzubringen letzte Woche ist die
satzungsveröffentlicht worden das heißt
es kann losgelegt werden der
klimafreundliche Umbau der Industrie ist
die Hauptaufgabe dieses klimaklubs wir
wollen gemeinsame Regeln und Standards
vereinbaren um Wettbewerbsverzerrungen
zu vermeiden um einen vollverkrieg zu
vermeiden genau das ist die Idee es wird
eine neue Dynamik beim Klimaschutz
entfesseln und er wird den globalen
Klimaziele die Erreichung dienen das ist
die Aufgabe dieses klima-clubs ja und es
ist unsere Aufgabe dass dieser klimaklub
einen offenen Charakter hat das auch
weitere Länder hinzutreten können das
auch Entwicklungs- und Schwellenländer
an dieser Stelle mitmachen können das
ist die Aufgabe dieses Klima Clubs da
sind wir einen großen nächsten Schritt
vorangegangen und lassen Sie mich einen
Strich darunter ziehen dieses Jahr war
herausfordernd dieses Jahr war für die
Menschen in der Bundesrepublik
herausfordernd es war auch für die
Parlamentarier und für die Regierung
herausfordernd weil wir Krisen meistern
mussten die so nicht zu kommen weil
nicht zu sehen waren am Anfang dieses
Jahres mir ist es wichtig und das kann
man unter dem Strich sagen wir lassen
uns in Europa nicht von Putin Spalten
wir stehen als Europa zusammen die
Antwort auf
putinsangriffskrieg auf die Ukraine ist
eine geschlossen ist eine solidarische
Europäische Union vielen Dank meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren
ich schließe die Aussprache und
unterbreche die Sitzung bis 14 Uhr der
Wiederbeginn wird Ihnen rechtzeitig
durch das übliche Klingelsignal bekannt
gegeben